Oh people are here fast so many people
here fast everyone wants that margul
moves okay so we jetted back here pretty
quick I started seeing all this news
dropping we were not in Hall age today
we weren't fortunate enough some cool
cool stuff we got to do though
separately but man it was like Marvel
news dropping left and right feel free
to chime in on the chat here okay so
which one I want to get a taste for what
everyone here is really freaking out
about that's the one okay the people
I've already brought it up Marvel Thor
the word love and thunder once I heard
that Natalie Portman was on stage I was
like what the hell Natalie Portman doing
back here because there was all that
talk about you know she really wanted to
she was like got away from the MCU but
then she showed up at the Avengers end
game premiere and people are like oh
that's cool then she had like a little
cameo in endgame but people were like
maybe that was just you know deleted
footage that was not used you know what
I mean she came to talk about that yeah
but now oh dude the the fact that she's
gonna be playing like lady Thor that's
exciting because it seems like what
Marvel is doing in this next phase is
especially when you just see what they
did with endgame they're taking it in
all these directions that you didn't
think we're possible just from hearing
about the what-ifs animated series that
you know like a lot of the things that
were talked about at this panel are
things that a lot of us already knew for
sure you know a lot of us knew about the
Eternals she changed Black Widow but the
thing about shang-chi though that got me
excited for the longest time we're at
comic-con right now but when we were at
to wonder how on movie fight when we
were at WonderCon my argument that I
made was like which Marvel villain
should make over to turn and I made this
whole argument for that they should get
a new Mandarin in their reveal who the
real Mandarin is that the MCU started
off with a little hint about the ten
rings you know he gets captured by the
ten rings Tony Stark and we still never
had a resolution on the ten ring so
calling a change key and what what's the
actual official title think it's changed
in the legend of the ten ring endo in
and and and the legend of the ten rings
or strangest I'm gonna be I'm gonna be
getting everything I wanted from the
manor ever seems like we're gonna be
getting to ten rings really in here as
well as the real man room at Tony Leung
which I know a lot of a like huge fans
of the guy are really excited about it
so yeah time fika was at your movie
fight I know right look if anything
happens to else like just random news
come out while we're on this live stream
please feel free to dimension it right
now there's a drop but shang-chi that
one I'm very excited for really because
of like we've already expressed our
excitement so much for Shane Chi but you
know like the idea of the Heather like
oh we're doing a real Mandarin that gets
you really excited natalie portman
returning seems they're gonna be nude
like some and fantastic what Fantastic
Four was just confirmed fantastic morbus
is good for her what the hell I did I
just found out about original cast yo
and Griff chefs out throw Olivia whoa
dude did they have any cast reveal for
that yet we're getting updates as we're
doing this right now the holy [ __ ]
before officially comfort this is just
gonna kind of be damned damn plays are
visually coming back it is they're going
way beyond their like just regular phase
four slash lineup to heavily crap I do
not know wow I thought it was over the
panel was over this just keeps getting
crazier and crazier I'm making up for
that late start today did they say is is
this true I'm hearing people in the
chatter say my Hirsch Holly I feel like
that's wish oh damn oh okay I mean they
have course yeah but damn did they had a
blade official title uh come up on stage
that's exciting that's rad and
unexpected I did hear that we were
hearing on Twitter that they were saying
there's gonna be an official daredevil
movie it's not part of the official like
paper lineup that we saw you know if
it's like the timeline thing they always
show but you know that would still be
really cool question is who's going to
be playing daredevil in that one yeah
someone give a second chance
okay so man blades gonna be in there
holy [ __ ] oh my god that's that super
excited for for some more Horde Omar so
he's on stage I really goddamn I kind of
want to go oh yeah and they said that
end game officially past avatar well I
saw him Box Office Mojo Calm I still 5
million behind but I'm pretty sure like
after this weekend when the numbers are
officially reported that endgame is
officially the highest-grossing movie of
all time
yeah momentarily what else do they
confirm on there like over you're just
kidding a bunch of like live reacting
like people are gonna lose their minds
yeah we're gonna wait to hear but yeah
though there's some real this was true
Blake on you know what I found really
fascinating about the way this this
lineup is looking is well before we go
on the livestream about half of the
things that were announcing the official
lineup were the TV shows like the Disney
Plus shows which is really interesting
to me because you know usually just the
movies they like when they have like all
they like age as a shield and then the
Netflix shows you those weren't really
being factored in and this seems like
the actual time were like what they were
talking about when agents of shield
first went on could actually come to
fruition like you actually see a fair
amount of world sharing between the
shows and between those characters right
you know practically everybody from the
movies now is getting a show yes yes
well hey babe can you me a favorite can
you look up who's uh well how about you
guys just tell me who's gonna who are
all the animated there's a lot of
returning voice actors inside of the
what the what ifs which sounds really
cool so like John it's not a quick
picture of it I saw
Rud yeah you had what's-her-name
hailey at way oh yeah well Jeffrey right
is gonna join that cat I think play hope
you peach yeah if they go are with that
I would be so I hope they go this is
gonna be really hard to stay on track as
we're getting news as we're trying to
get it's like I I did hear the thing
about the daredevil that they announced
in a movie but you know it's like the
question is with Charlie Cox be returned
but we're gonna stick with what's really
being revealed online right now is
everything that is official or her shali
is blade that's a perfect choice I hope
it's r-rated I'm letting one thing that
got me really excited beyond the fact
that I look fantastic for x-men of
course it is of course it is black
panther to Captain Marvel - oh yeah we
knew about those you knew about those
alright okay so we knew about most of
these of course x-men but damn it's cool
to hear it's cool to hear that they're
confirming it on stage at Comic Con it's
really great to hear and Space Jam 3
Space Jam 3 confront rehearsal they
joining Don Cheadle LeBron James
Fantastic Four that's really exciting to
me and my favorite early phases Marvel
movies and not only to get you know the
follow-up to that but also have the
multi with madness in the multiverse
like because far from home came out and
you know the whole Mysterio thing
everyone's like is he telling the truth
about the multiverse right I like that
we're gonna actually delve into that
yeah yeah the Doctor Strange News sounds
really cool man I heard they sang happy
birthday to Benedict Cumberbatch on
stage you know we're not time to do a
full-on professional letter to video
your we get it back to the raw while
we're heading yes so blade is back what
else have we now really talked about
okay I mean the Eternals is everything
we already heard about right like I
don't know
Angelina Jolie other than how cool it is
to see Angelina Jolie showing up on stay
like that must be really exciting to see
her their nightmare for the villain and
Doctor Strange - that sounds emos
returning for the this Winter Soldier
falcon show which sounds really great
I've heard he's gonna transform into
Baron by that time they said they showed
an image of him in the purple mask with
a girly cool get up so that sounds
really awesome man all these are great
actor but not really scary at all for
blade is blade really scary he could be
pretty cool that's true man I'm
wondering fitting and blade into this it
really seems like they're expanding the
[ __ ] out of their universe about who
lives amongst us already if you're
getting exponent there you got to figure
out the whole thing about mutants first
off and then you're getting blade in
there then you gotta figure out the
whole thing about vampires living
amongst us so you got this whole other
expansion of world happening right now
I'm so excited to see what's up you know
I honestly like they said Marvel
faithful they said Kevin Feige would be
showing up yeah and he would be and they
officially announced Marvel only like a
month ago so I didn't think that really
announced all that much and you know
they haven't they haven't reviewed it
called stupid Rena they haven't revealed
any trailers online I heard they showed
some black Black Widow footage but
there's no trailers online yet of course
we'd be covering that right away
there was black widow trailer just drop
you're messing with you're [ __ ] with
us right there's no black widow trailer
there's no black anyway oh yeah the
other point I wanted to go back to
really fast was how they were saying
that I know how they're showing with a
lineup how so much of what's officially
part of the lineup they're they're
really making sure to emphasize their
shows really showing that Kevin Feige is
gonna be as involved in shepherding this
series and how integral it is gonna be
to the next coming phase so it makes it
does add that feeling of okay in order
to truly keep up with everything I need
to commit to watching these shows and
these shows are gonna be an integral
part to even completing the whole
journey of you know whatever the next
mashup movie is by the end of phase four
or beginning of phase five whatever
affair Elena because they haven't they
haven't announced an official New
Avengers movie yet right okay no
official news alright so what do we got
let's recap we pull like a widow first
black widow one division we got Loki
what did you pop we're going back Black
Widow
then we got Falcon and Winter Soldier
then the Eternals in November Shane and
GE February 21 one division Doctor
Strange in the multiverse madness yeah
okay what if Hawkeye Thor love and
thunder I make so I love how the Hawkeye
titles like close to the original Marvel
logo that's right yeah but dude I mean
freaking Natalie Portman returning door
that's nuts have that character you know
who's kind of an iffy character at least
in the you know integration into the
movies to have her ostensively take up
an even heavier mantle and become like a
yes West hero like I really wonder what
they worked out with her to get that and
if she's gonna like bulk the heck up ya
gonna like really get strong for this Oh
what more importantly Aquafina is gonna
be unchanged alright that's the biggest
one okay is there any news that we are
officially missing at all how are you
guys yeah we didn't we had no idea about
blade and Fantastic Four being talked
about that's pretty crazy yeah yeah
that's all like the speculation stuff
and honestly panel has okay you know
we're gonna stay with you guys just a
little bit longer until the panel has
ended itself which which one are you
guys most excited for yeah let's hear
mutants working for of hope mutants were
confirmed as well as how about x-men oh
thanks mace windu I hope there's a video
of everything getting revealed so it's
phase four oppa how do I pull that
question up it's phase four just for
movies and everything else TV shows and
blade and everything phase five that's a
great question I mean it sounds like
that
what they're developing before they put
it on an official timeline is the stuff
like blade Fantastic Four x-men and
whatever and but the stuff that's like
really in production right now or like a
solid pre-production is the ones that
have been officially announced on their
other a cool little yeah title phase
four seems to be everything from Black
Widow up until for love and thunder
surprise number twenty one so have we
got in the guardians of the galaxy a
three-day yet well cuz he's got Suicide
Squad
breaking news DC has mouthing babe
nothing still oh what the Snider cut
well someone someone super chatted us
totally missed it where to go where to
go
Oh Eric rush Sean Shrek five confirmed
is it really that was worth the two
bucks right there appreciate that buddy
that would be pretty neat okay
toku kids so far nothing on spider-man
maybe soon well spider-man far from
Howard has just come out I don't think
they even have a plot you know
officially mapped out for what they want
like they have ideas I'm sure about
don't think they have anything holding
no tire their official is that home will
be in the title yes they got a complete
that home truly for spider-man you know
goes to college far from campus is part
but I honestly think like all these in
now I've never been this excited about
the announcement style like as he as it
things were coming out and we were
hearing about the cast over coming on
thanks Cara Lovejoy Star Wars z23 buddy
wait for d23 Carter but as as all these
announcements were coming out I was like
re I've heard this I've heard I heard we
heard something from a few people on
Twitter that they they mentioned
something about a standalone Hulk movie
but there's no confirmation we were able
to find that out that's what I am
believing in that that would be a big
deal because that would mean that they
have like fully risa cured those right
yeah through Universal and be the first
Mark Ruffalo movie do Bobby Stevens
thanks so much buddy
what was the question you had for us
amigo
what's the what-if thing I just got done
with work the what s is basically like
two random alternate versions you take
on a lot of our characters you know like
one idea that John I've always wanted to
see is like what if spider-man had like
a body horror there's like like I saw I
remember the episode of the animated
spider-man series is based on a comic
but like what if he had like freaked out
yeah imagine something like doing
whatever random what-ifs I don't know
what what is sort of going well but
they're getting a lot of the original
actors to voice them again I'm really
excited for that I think that's where
you might be able to see your little
Marvel Zombies at some point
oh yeah be awesome because it would be
awesome I really like one thing that
excites me the most is to see Marvel go
off road you know that's actually not a
bad title spider-man can't go back home
on Reeves
MCU of course we like to see me MCU
maybe he'll be in guardians of the
galaxy 3 thou be awesome
man you just imagine have comic-con
broke today with geography who's on the
panel at Marvel that would have been the
number one most talked about nuts okay
so it's officially over that's all the
news oh wow okay
our Comic Con was spent knowing that
like a couple blocks away all these and
which led to we got our hurry back to
the hotel get some solid internet and
talk about this ran up Fifth Avenue and
we prepared just in case a black widow
trailer drop didn't but we got a lot of
killer now honestly yeah like this is
the most expensive John is adorable oh
thank you and by the way there's a lot
of people at comic-con who have been
recognizing us as by the most recognize
we were Vince - thank you to everyone
who said hi to us and by the way the
dark web panel has been goin great
that's the main reason we came out here
and that's been awesome so it's live on
Amazon Prime now look we don't make this
livestream too long but you're still out
here in San Diego we wanted to make sure
to jump in here and talk about some of
this news I'm excited I'm excited for
everything and yeah please share this
video there's some live reactions in
here so please Jerry great if you guys
did
I love all these terrible spider-man
titles you guys are coming up with a
sound amazing thank you alright guys
well if you're new here just happening
someone here subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell like button we do like Marvel's the
biggest thing so we didn't want to make
sure we got to talk about it we don't
really have time to edit anything but
when we get back home to LA we'll to
make some time to cover like Watchmen
and The Witcher and look out for those
videos and whatnot much love thank you
to everyone for chiming in here these
are our most watched livestream ever we
will talk with you guys soon thank you
again people watching